DELIBERATIONS ARE EXPECTED NEXT
WEEK, ACCORDING TO THE JUDGE.
>>> CIVIL RIGHTS ATTORNEY BEN
CRUMP JOINS US NOW.
AS WE MENTIONED, HE REPRESENTS
GEORGE FLOYD'S FAMILY AND DUANTE
WRIGHT'S FAMILY, AS WELL.
GOOD MORNING.
I WANT TO START WITH THE
TESTIMONY THAT WE HEARD
YESTERDAY.
YOU KNOW, WE HEARD THAT EXPERT
SAY -- USE THE WORDS "RESTING
COMFORTABLY."
HE WAS CERTAINLY CALLED ON THAT.
HE SAID THE RESTRAINTS WERE
JUSTIFIED, THE EXACT OPPOSITE OF
WHAT THE PROSECUTOR SAID LAST
WEEK.
AT ONE POINT HE SAID POLICE
DON'T HAVE TO FIGHT FAIR.
WHAT DID YOU MAKE OF HIS
TESTIMONY YESTERDAY?
>> I THOUGHT IT WAS A DESPERATE
ATTEMPT TO DISTRACT US.
WE ALL SAW, GAYLE, GEORGE FLOYD
FACE DOWN, HANDCUFFED, POSING NO
THREAT TO THOSE OFFICERS.
WHAT HE WAS TRYING TO DO WAS TO
BREATHE.
HE WAS TRYING TO EXTEND HIS
LIFE.
AND IF THAT IS RESISTING ARREST,
I GUESS WE ALL DO, THAT GAYLE.
WE ALL WANT TO EXTEND LIFE.
THAT'S ALL GEORGE FLOYD
DESPERATELY WAS TRYING TO DO WAS
TAKE ANOTHER BREATH.
>> MR. CRUMP, THE JUDGE SAYS
THAT CLOSING ARGUMENTS ARE
EXPECTED NEXT WEEK.
SO I SUPPOSE IT'S NOT TOO SOON
TO START TALKING ABOUT HOW THE
CASE IS GOING AND WHAT YOU THINK
THE CONCLUSION WILL BE.
WE SHOULD REMIND PEOPLE THAT YOU
AND YOUR TEAM NEED 12 JURORS TO
VOTE GUILTY TO GET A CONVICTION
HERE.
THE DEFENSE ONLY NEEDS ONE TO
SAY NO, NOT GUILTY.
WITH THAT IN MIND, HOW DO YOU
THINK THINGS ARE GOING?
>> WELL, I THINK ATTORNEY
GENERAL KEITH ELLISON AND HIS
TEAM OF PROSECUTORS ARE MAKING A
VERY COMPELLING CASE WHY DEREK
CHAUVIN SHOULD BE HELD
CRIMINALLY LIABLE FOR KILLING
GEORGE FLOYD.
BUT AS I'VE SAID BEFORE, I'VE
BEEN A CIVIL RIGHTS ATTORNEY FOR
THE BALANCE OF MY PROFESSIONAL
CAREER, BUT I'VE BEEN BLACK ALL
MY LIFE.
AND I KNOW WE CAN NEVER, EVER
TAKE FOR GRANTED IN AMERICA THAT
A POLICE OFFICER WOULD BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR KILLING A BLACK
PERSON UNJUSTLY NO MATTER HOW
MUCH EVIDENCE WE HAVE.
>> MR. CRUMP, I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT THE SHOOTING OF DUANTE
WRIGHT FOR A SECOND.
THE OFFICER WHO FIRED THE SHOT,
KIM POTTER, A VETERAN OFFICER,
RESIGNED YESTERDAY.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT
DECISION?
>> WELL, LIKE DUANTE'S FAMILY,
WE DON'T THINK IT'S FAIR THAT
SHE CAN KILL HIM AND SAY I MADE
A MISTAKE AND THEN RESIGN AND
D
KEEP ALL HER BENEFITS AND
PENSIONS.
SHE SHOULD BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE
TO THE FULL EXTENT OF THE LAW.
THE FACT THAT SHE'S A 26-YEAR
VETERAN WHO, GAYLE, TONY,
ANTHONY, SHE WAS TRAINING
OFFICERS.
>> YES.
>> HER DOMINANT HAND SIDE, HER
TASER'S ON HER NONDOMINANT HAND
SIDE.
2.6 POUNDS.
THE TASER WEIGHS EIGHT OUNCES.
THE TASER HAS A BRIGHT YELLOW
STRIP ON IT.
THE GUN IS ALL BLACK.
AND I'M SORRY, SHE DID NOT HAVE
TO EVEN TASE THIS YOUNG MAN.
IT WAS A MISDEMEANOR WARRANT.
THEY ALWAYS SEEM TO DO THE MOST
-- ENGAGE IN THE MOST EXCESSIVE
USE OF FORCE WHEN IT'S A
MARGINALIZED MINORITY.
AND GEORGE FLOYD, THEY COULD
HAVE GIVEN HIM A TICKET FOR THIS
ALLEGED OF A $20 FRAUDULENT
BILL.
THEY COULD HAVE GIVEN HIM A
TICKET.
THEY DID NOT HAVE TO ARREST HIM.
BUT WHEN IT'S BLACK PEOPLE, THEY
SEEM TO ENGAGE IN THE MOST
EXCESSIVE FORCE JUST LIKE THE
LIEUTENANT IN VIRGINIA.
>> YEAH.
I THINK IT'S SO IMPORTANT TO
KEEP REMINDING PEOPLE THAT THE
GEORGE FLOYD CASE STARTED WITH A
COUNTERFEIT BILL.
WE DON'T KNOW IF HE KNEW IT WAS
COUNTERFEIT.
IN THE RICE CASE IT STARTED WITH
-- WRIGHT CASE IT STARTED WITH
AN EXPIRED TAG AND ESCALATED
INTO THAT.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO REMIND PEOPLE
THESE ARE MINOR THINGS THAT
TURNED DEADLY SO QUICKLY.
YOU REPRESENT BOTH FAMILIES WHO
NOW BELONG TO A CLUB THAT NOBODY
WANTS TO BELONG TO.
THESE ARE DIFFERENT CASES, BUT
THE EMOTIONS ARE CERTAINLY THE
SAME.
THE FEELINGS ARE THE SAME, AND
THE CIRCUMSTANCES ARE SIMILAR.
IT LOOKED TO ME, IT WAS LIKE A
SUMMIT OF SORROW TO SEE THE TWO
FAMILIES TOGETHER.
WHAT DID THEY SAY TO EACH OTHER,
AND DO YOU THINK THAT THEY --
HOW DID THEY HELP EACH OTHER?
IT HAD TO BE ON SOME LEVEL
COMFORTING TO BE ABLE TO TALK
FACE TO FACE.
>> GAYLE KING, THAT'S AN
EXCELLENT WAY TO DEFINE THE
SUMMIT OF SORROW BECAUSE GEORGE
FLOYD'S FAMILY ABOUT THERE TIME
LAST YEAR WAS DEALING WITH THIS
UNTHINKABLE INTRUSION INTO THEIR
LIVES.
AND NOW THEY ARE HAVING TO TELL
DUANTE WRIGHT'S MOTHER, FATHER,
HIS BABY'S MOTHER WHAT THEY'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO ENDURE.
THE ASSAULT ON HIS CHARACTER,
TRYING TO ASSASSINATE HIS
CHARACTER AFTER THEY
ASSASSINATED HIS PERSON.
ABOUT HOW THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO GRIEVE IN THE PUBLIC'S EYE.
YOU KNOW, HIS MOTHER IS GOING TO
GET HIS BODY BACK TO THE FUNERAL
HOME FOR THE FIRST TIME TODAY.
SO SHE'S DEALING WITH THAT ALL
THE TIME WHILE WE EXPECT THERE
TO BE SOME ANNOUNCEMENT WHETHER
THEY'RE GOING TO CHARGE THE
OFFICER OR NOT.
SO THE BROTHERS OF GEORGE FLOYD
WERE JUST TRYING TO EXPLAIN TO
THEM NO MATTER WHAT, YOU HAVE A
GOOD SUPPORT SYSTEM, AND EVERY
DAY YOU JUST TRY TO BREATHE.
YOU JUST TRY TO BREATHE BECAUSE
THERE'S -- THERE IS NO RIGHT OR
WRONG IN THIS.
THERE'S NOTHING FAIR ABOUT THIS.
>> DO YOU THINK THAT DEREK
CHAUVIN WILL OR SHOULD TAKE THE
STAND?
>> WELL, AS AN ATTORNEY, GAYLE,
WE WILL ALWAYS DEFER TO NEVER TO
LET YOUR CLIENT TAKE THE STAND.
BUT NORMALLY, IF YOUR CLIENT
TAKES THE STAND, IT IS A
DESPERATE, DESPERATE EFFORT TO
TRY TO MAKE SURE THAT HE IS --
THAT'S THE ONLY WAY AND THE ONLY
REASON I WOULD SEE HIM TAKING
THE STAND IS IF THEY FEEL
DESPERATE.
>> YEAH.
WELL, CONVERSATION FOR ANOTHER
DAY.
WE KEEP THESE STORIES -- THESE
STORIES KEEP REPEATING.
WE HAVE ANOTHER NAME ADDED TO
THE HASH TAG LIST.
I'M TIRED OF REPORTING THEM.
I'M SURE YOU'RE TIRED OF TRYING
THEM, BEING INVOLVED.
WE HAVE TO TALK ABOUT SYSTEMIC
POLICE REFORM.
REALLY ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THERE'S
A PROBLEM IN THIS COUNTRY WITH
THE BLACK COMMUNITY AND THE
POLICE.
AND MOST POLICE DO THEIR JOB AND
DO IT WELL.
AND WE -- IT'S HEARTBREAKING TO
ME, BEN, THAT WE HAVE TO KEEP
HAVING THE SAME CONVERSATION
OVER AND OVER AND OVER AGAIN,
AND NOTHING CHANGES.
>> GAYLE, I CANNOT BELIEVE
WITHIN TEN MILES OF WHERE DEREK
CHAUVIN HAD BEEN TRIED FOR
KILLING GEORGE FLOYD IT IS -- I
CAN'T FATHOM THAT ANOTHER POLICE
OFFICER KILLED ANOTHER UNARMED
BLACK MAN.
>> YEP.
>> YOU WOULD THINK DURING THIS
TIME THEY WOULD USE THE GREATEST
STANDARD OF CARE.
>> YES.
>> THEY WOULD DO EVERYTHING TO
DEESCALATE.
I'M JUST -- I'M JUST HEARTBROKEN
AND SHOCKED.